[Music]
well leave it to olivia rodrigo to
inspire a precious family moment this
one between selena gomez and her sister
gracie i don't think my sister
overthinks anything she's excited about
life yeah and we're excited to see a
heartwarming embrace between these two
oh my goodness the only murders in the
building star shares the throwback vid
to tiktok when she and her baby sis
attended one of olivia's sour tour
concerts oh my gosh they're like singing
song which is so cute
and cute isn't even the half of it
[Music]
check out olivia and gracie letting
driver's license take the wheel of their
emotions
[Music]
[Music]
yeah olivia's chart topper appears to
bring out the feels in everyone as
selena's snl friends hilariously proved
last season
[Applause]
of course this isn't the first time
gracie's made cameos and selena's tick
tocks
i just deleted the little tit
like the time selena tried to prove she
was social media savvy yeah you
embarrassed me as gracie teases her big
sis didn't fare any better on snapchat
you see this is where it's at snapchat
is where
wait what
snapchat
and remember their lip sync of this
classic full house moment i'm older i'm
younger i'm taller i'm stronger i'm
smarter i'm
not falling for that when selena's not
sharing emotional flashbacks we know
she's keeping busy i am in the studio
i'm excited yup and this week the former
disney stars even teasing her latest
collab
[Music]
she's blessing fans with a remix for one
of rima's debut hits calm down
i'm
really excited to see the person that
asked me to be on a song that
i couldn't be more honored to do so
this song's fun i hope people like it
that's all i want
[Music]
[Applause]
literally
[Music]
and as far as we can tell celine is
having a ball back in the studio
[Music]
yeah we can also count on gracie to
champion for selena's music she's my
biggest supporter it's awesome
[Music]